well there's two different ways like I
said one way is they'll just say you
know a ship or an airplane or an object
is heading at a bearing or with a
bearing of let's say 210 degrees now
we're used to measuring angles in such a
way that we start off facing the
positive x-direction and we had
counterclockwise if it's a positive
angle and then clockwise if it's a
negative angle but when you find bearing
what you do is you orientate yourself in
these cardinal directions the north east
south west you start facing north and if
it says a bearing of 210 you would
measure clockwise from the north 210
degrees and there you would be right
there so you start facing north and you
go clockwise okay so that's one way
that's when they just say bearing now
another way is they'll give you some
other coordinates we'll say north 20
degrees west or south 30 degrees east
when they give it to you in this form
what what you want to do is you want to
start facing in the direction of that
first letter so you'd say I'm going to
face north and I'm going to start to
turn 20 degrees towards the second
letter towards the west so I'm facing
north 20 degrees towards the west that's
our angle right there 20 degrees now if
we want to find this angle here you just
do 90 minus 20 because that's the right
angle let's look at this one south 30
degrees east we start facing south and
then you go 30 degrees towards the east
okay like that so this would be like a
30-degree angle right there so those two
different ways of measuring bearings
let's go through a couple examples
together so it says say you're heading
out north 21.8 degrees east okay so this
one is just saying okay we're going to
face north we're gonna head towards the
east remember never eat sour watermelon
you go in that direction like that
so start facing north and we're heading
twenty one point eight degrees towards
the east
so that's right there a second example
it says a ship heads south 70 degrees
west for 10 miles another ship heads
south 40 degrees east for 15 miles how
far apart of the ships okay this is a
good problem let's see if we can draw
this what you want to draw is you want
to draw your coordinate axis like this
label your directions north east south
west
start at the origin and one ship is
heading south so we face south seventy
degrees towards the west like that so
this is a 70 degree angle and it's going
for 10 miles so I'm just going to write
10 miles the other one is South 40
degrees east so we start facing south
and we had 40 degrees towards the east
approximately right there and that's for
15 miles it's a little bit longer so
that's south 40 degrees towards the east
now we're trying to find the distance
between these two ships and that's right
there and what you notice is we have
this side-angle-side situation so when
you have side-angle-side like that and
you're looking for this length here you
can use the law of cosines and you can
review some of my videos talk about law
of cosines if you need to review that
but we'll set it up here so basically we
have a total of a hundred and ten
degrees for that angle that's in between
the two sides 10 and 15 so what we would
do is we'd say x squared equals 10
squared plus 15 squared minus 2 times 10
times 15 times the cosine of the
included angle which is 110 degrees then
what you would do since you're just
solving for x and not x squared you
would take the square root of this whole
thing and that's going to give you the
distance between the two ships so again
two different ways to measure bearing
either from the north clockwise or the
second way start facing the first letter
either north or south and then you're
gonna head towards that second ladder
east or west that many degrees so I hope
this helped you understand bearing a
little bit better subscribe to the
channel check out more math tutoring
videos on my youtube channel Mario's
math tutoring and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon